travail dur travail dur toute l'année
franchement on peut pas se reposer il
faut du
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
repos
alors quoi de beau salut à tous alors
quoi de beau ce weekend dans les
evelines j'espère que vous avez passé
des bonnes vacances moi c'est le cas il
fait super chaud ici on est au Cambodge
donc là c'est pas la météo du Cambodge
il fait actuellement 31°gr je crois mais
ressenti 56 et demi 76 % d'humidité je
suis en sueur je transpire à l'aide ça
fait squck quick entre les jambes ici
apparemment c'est
l'hiver énorme et donc c'est la période
de mousson donc il y a beaucoup de pluie
bonà là il y en a pas mais là
il il
beaucoup
mais je connais quelques
mot c'est quoi les je crois que je suis
biling l'essentiel c'est ch tout ça on
s'est s'amuser au Cambodge mi
Mang comment ça va allez bon ici c'est
méga hosyle tout est hosyle il y a des
Scorpions des serpents des
chiens
la journée internationale du verre de
terre est-ce que vous savez ce qui se
passe samedi aucune idée ah non non non
non non non grosse journée samedi hein
ouais un petit rébut il y a exactement
la réponse devant vos yeux terre euh je
sais pas c'est la moitié déjà déjà bonne
moitié c'est la deuxième partie de la
moitié par exemple qu'est-ce qu' est
devant vous là moi je vois de l'herbe
des feuilles mais il y a quelque chose
qui bouge ah bon non c'est peut-être moi
vous êtes pas pressé non là il y a la
réponse devant vous là le contenu et le
contenant ici non ah tu à peut-être chop
ah ouais c'est la fête à la grenouille à
la nature c'est beau mais c'est pas ça
il y a des petites bêtes j'ai pas vu euh
non je crois pas on n pas ressensé quoi
que ce soit pour le moment le contenant
le contenant le vert terre terre vert
vert de terre allez
ouais c'est la journée des verr de terre
samedi j'adore les vers de terre ah
ah il y a un verre oui c'est la moitié
ah oui c'est la journée du verre de
terre alors c'est un verre de terre là
mais je le vois pas moi bah si il est là
il est devant vous c'est un verre avec
de la
terre c'est
formidable d'accord mais moi je voyais
la nature avec votre herbe mais ouais
elle est belle hein elle est
belle et dedans il y a quoi de l'herbe
ah ah un verre d'herbe merde et en
dessous de l'herbe il y a
quoi qui est marron feues des feuilles
ouais vert de feu qui est marron qui est
marron peut-être que vous avez le
mauvais mauvais angle ouais peut-être
qu'il faut que je tourne vous voyez pas
non je vois pas si on vous dit que c'est
de la terre de la terre glaise ouais de
la terre de terre glaise la terre oui
non bah sans le glaise terre verte oui
ça fait quoi une plante il y a un verre
dans le ver ah bon ça c'est un ver et ça
c'est un ver ah oui m' eu avec ma
blague pas mal dit que c'est un animal
ouais un être vivant qui est souvent
dans la terre un verre de terre
ok c'est ça un ver de terre ver de terre
bam
ouais et là par exemple si moi je
cherche un verre de terre à mettre dans
mon verre de terre où est-ce que je
vaisre un peu une petite pelouse par
là-bas allez très bien vous avez un
jardin vous là oui on vous compagner
chercher des vers de terre chez vous non
mais est-ce que je peux en voler un pour
le mettre dans mon verre de terre le
verre de terre ah bah faut fouiller dans
le compost ah ouais bah il sait faire ça
c'est fouillé vous le ciel vous fouillez
la terre et ben c'est bien venez c'est
pas beau ça allez c'est beau ça allez
vous appelez comment moi je m'appelle
Sylvie enchanté Sylvie moi c'est Thomas
Thomas d'accord et ben écoutez moi mon
petit jardin il est là c'est le jardin
secret ou pas non on est plusieurs on
est deux faut quelqu'un qui fait les
petites choses et quelqu'un qui pense
les grandes choses OK et ma copine elle
pense les grandes choses B nous on
cherche les petites choses ah ben ça va
samedi en fait c'est la journée
internationale des vers de
terre c'est extraordinaire ça devrait
être tous les jours que vous savez on a
des poules ah mais on leur donne pas des
ver de terre à manger sont van ouais
j'aimerais bien qu'ell le devienne quand
les poules auront des dents elles
deviendront végan c'est chez vous là
alors mon regardez mon installation
alors je vais vous montrer mon compost
je vous laisserai fouiller dedans ou
allez super
allez je ge mon paraplu allez-y donc
elles sont belles mais elles sont bien
mouillées hein alors vous dites quoi
bonjour elles sont très calines c'est
marrant je ne pensais pas qu'un animal
comme une poule vous être comme un
animal domes entendu mais vraiment
j'avais déjà entendu quand on arrive
viennent et puis on va les prendre on le
fait un petit câlin ce sont des poires
de terre et ben figurez-vous que ça
existe et que c'est délicieux c'est donc
je vous ai dit on est à deux sur le on
un verre de terre mais vous avez des
poires de terre des poires de terre
c'est succulent il est gros votre
compost j'ai toute confiance en vous qui
est journaliste ou ou oui oui m
l'enquête l'qute ver de terre pouvez
enquêter dans le alors vous voulez des
gants je sais pas pourquoi
pas merci beaucoup là on est sur une
grosse enquête quand même on est sur une
très grosse enquête à la main oui oui
ououi fait ce que vous pouvez j'en ai vu
un Patrick j'en ai un comment ça j'en ai
mais ça se fauile j'ai peur de les
casser madame c'est sol ver et pu si
vous le coupez en de il revit en deux
parties ça repousse si je coupe en 16 on
en a 16 metle dans le ver
voir ah ouais voilà il y a un verre de
terre dans le verre de terre ah ouais he
on a réussi il suffit de venir au jardin
et ben merci Sylvie de rien et mais le
compost c'est tout un art ça c'est une
belle
[Musique]
mission oh ça arrive ça arrive ça arrive
oh
[Musique]
c'est ver c'est be
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est c'est
ver